in this video we will be racing on the
hardest gta maps
ever created let's do it
the track is now loading we got me we
got chris hey
we got carl hello and we got chandler
all right everybody
start your engines okay now this first
track is crazy because it has a
really big ramp oh my gosh and while i'm
going down this ramp carl you want to
let him know what the punishment is for
whoever comes in last the punishment is
that you have to walk around walmart
with peanut butter in your shoes it's
the same punishment from the fall guys
video why do we just keep bringing it
back but since we didn't lose
we never did it so now we're gonna do it
again because it's funny chandler do you
like peanut butter in your shoes no
i hate it when i have peanut butter my
shoes who's in last place right now me
i'm in first chandler at this rate
you're gonna have to put peanut butter
in your shoes my controller isn't
working
i had to switch to the keyboard sounds
like an excuse i'm gonna be transparent
yeah let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go
jimmy's at you right behind me yeah i
think i have a flat tire no it's because
you're in the dirt road it was the dirt
road
yeah there's a dirt road there act like
you've been here before i haven't
i haven't been here actually carl you're
no longer competing with me and chris
you're competing with chandler wait i'm
i
am like right behind you guys i gotta
get first place i'm so bad i'm on
keyboard
i kind of like having chris in front of
me because then i can just just watch
where to go and then just do what he
does are you doing the loop did you guys
do the loop are you skipping oh yeah we
skipped oh you're supposed to do that i
didn't even know i always skipped a loop
buddy
hey hey chandler how's it going back
there i'm getting screwed
chandler's so far behind but it's not
fair like
it was rigged from the beginning no it
wasn't the controller didn't work are
you good with the loop-de-loose jimmy oh
yeah look at that
oh look at that oh look at that you're
doing good
you're doing good hitting that wall but
look at that hey carl beat jimmy now
can i he had to reset ah oh i'm ahead of
jimmy this isn't fair
hey chandler you can catch up to me now
no i can't i'm so behind
i'm so fast you already know
chris what car are you using i'm just
using any car it doesn't matter i'm just
good at driving in gta
chris i haven't hit one thing i've been
doing it for 10 years i'm just good at
it
chris i haven't crashed into one thing
just get better you got to time the
boost you got to get all that wait what
boost there's a boost at the beginning
just like mario party oh yeah no i know
all about mario party i mean mario
kart you know what i meant shut up hey
carl
yes see you later you're so much faster
what the heck you're just bad jimmy
jimmy
i think you just slacken i'm confused
are other people playing right now uh
i'm playing i'm so confused what's the
saying
i think it's first is the word second is
the best i could be confused what about
fourth though
this fourth is any good i'm just so
confused
i think i just got first place there i'm
gonna put my controller down
oh controller must be nice how you doing
chandler i don't want to talk to you
it's not my fault i didn't
you would be complaining so hard right
now if you were in my position
and i got second i don't know where i'm
going you're good you're good just go
straight just go straight don't help him
bro
finish line boom oh nice
okay so we're operating on a point
system chris
you have four points carl you have three
points
three i have two points chandler has one
the higher you place
the more points you get we're gonna do
two more races and then whoever has the
least amount of points has to wear
peanut butter in their shoes oh
give me this give me this you're gonna
break it since chandler is having so
many problems we're gonna have chris
switch with them because chris is in
first place wait we could bump into each
other i think
because we're not invisible this time
yeah hey co call stop stop stop i didn't
mean to i didn't mean to okay
wait you made it so we could pump it
yeah you bumped into it you made
hey guys i think we should all
collectively bully chris's car respond
respond what i just literally dropped
straight down i can't
not drop straight down with the mouse
wait why is my car upside down
wait how am i in second who'd i pass
please
wait why am i where are we going i
literally can't just not drop down
every time i just drop stroke no no wait
where do i go
where do i go wait i don't know how to
respawn you hold wide no why
on the controller yeah i don't have the
control okay hi i'm going home yeah
do you feel my pain the wall goes silent
the wall goes sideways
yes oh my gosh no no no no no no no no
no
jimmy how are you doing it yes this is
yes yes
just keep holding the gas pedal i don't
know what you mean i'm holding it down
did i just pass you carl i'm literally
stuck oh wait hey
i'm at the finish line hey i'm at the
finish line
i'm i i can't finish i literally cannot
finish oh someone's right behind me
yeah your boy i caught up you guys are
close to the end
chris is on my booty let's go i'm better
than you
all right i got first place chandler got
second place chris got third and carl
got last place i did it with a broken
setup too by the way
or you're going down baby this is the
third and final map this will decide
who has to wear peanut butter filled
shoes let's do it boys
holy cow i'm in the back too all right
let's go no peanut butter
don't mess up boys no peanut butter for
coral i like my shoes without peanut
butter
i started all the way in the back
literally can't see where i can't see
the road
whatever i can't see where i'm going oh
oh no you're gonna follow the boys
oh my gosh this is actually wild oh my
god oh no
you see that damn this is hard this is
really hard i didn't realize this but we
saved the hardest map for last i made it
halfway across
oh no no no no no no no no no no no
i don't want them ow ow am i on the map
somehow
i'm so sweaty all right we're gonna do
it first person mode see if it's easier
why is this door so tiny
this is so weird i don't know what to do
i'm getting star
i got flunk into the ground oh my gosh
look at this jump i am so sweaty i'm a
sweat god
are you doing good carl oh no no i'm not
am i the only one that's like not got
past this yet
what just happened i'm in second place i
don't know what to do
no i go he just
heeded me i'm insane you're good carl
okay you're good
am i good you're good you're good oh
what is this camera
no way i did it
[Applause]
how do you how do you do that i don't
get it
i'm a god i don't know how to do it it
just
the camera angle just yeets me every
time yo
chris you're gonna freak at this section
this is the hardest race i've ever done
i'm not even kidding whoa the jump
no what just happened come on
man i don't know how to do this i got it
i got it
nope wait what the frick oh jimmy yeah
you've been
i've been trying to do this part for
like forever chris i thought you were
sort of stuck on the first one no this
is so hard i i was stuck on the first
one
you gotta hit it oh i did it no no i did
it too
oh later nerd come on i can't get last
jimmy you'll mess up no no no no
the camera go
i'm falling yeah baby
yes got it yes yes
what i didn't have enough speed dude i
didn't make it through that jimmy first
go am i not upside down
i don't know i can't figure it out yes
why are there soccer balls
like it i can't make it i cannot make it
my hands are sweating so much
hey chris yeah good luck doing whatever
the hell i just did come on come on make
it make it make it make it make it
if i don't have enough speed i'm gonna
cry what what how am i not doing it
i'm literally doing it my camera's stuck
in reverse
chris you don't want to beat what you're
on it gets stupid
what do i do i don't get it i don't
think my car is fast enough to do this
jump
we all have the same car chris i don't
think it's fast enough
guys i'm just just throw me a bone here
just throw me a bone i just want to
finish stuck on this loop to loop
forever
don't know what the honk i was supposed
to do there yo there's so many things
later on you guys haven't even gotten i
can't get past this part
it's literally impossible i literally
just ice skated
in this game and then landed it baby
rake up
i'm a thug gamer landing baby
wait there's a second loop what
i don't understand what i'm supposed to
do
whoa i just jumped over the highest part
of the map
oh my god
i've tried every way
wait carl finished i cannot do this one
singular part
i think it's because of where i'm
starting what am i supposed to do
i don't understand chris i'm in the same
boat
i've been doing this for 10 minutes now
when's it going to end
there you go there you go chris
i swear to god if you if you beat this
on your first try chris all right soccer
balls i'm at the soccer balls oh you are
chris i believe in you dude
there was nothing i could do there was
nothing i could do you saw that the fan
was getting in the way
let's go what the heck am i doing wrong
keep going up
i did it did i finish let's go third
third third third after the third and
final race chris and carl both have
eight points so they are safe
calm down calm down but me and chandler
both have seven
how do we settle this rock paper
scissors let's do one and done
rock paper scissors shoot
i quit the channel okay oh
my god he's coming up it's so gross oh
my god
that's the grossest thing i've seen it's
like a slime
like it's like slimy